What will the Muslim army do when it has
conquered your infidel
[Music]
land? If you don't want to convert to
Islam, the Muslims will take your money
in exchange for your
life. This extortion is called Jiza.
Most of Westerners have no clue what
Jiza is and thinking that Jiza is an
example of tolerance in
Islam. The most obvious examples of the
implementation of Jiza in the modern
world is what the Islamic State has done
to non-believers in this case Christians
in terms of Jiza. In the event where the
Islamic State slaughters some 30
Christian Ethiopians in Libya on April
2015, the spokesman repeatedly pointed
out that payment of Jiza is the only way
for Christians around the world to
safeguard their lives. But whoever
refuses to pay a Jiza will see nothing
from us but the edge of a spear. The men
will be killed and the children will be
enslaved and their wealth will be taken
as buddhies. This is the judgment of
Allah and his messenger.
When the Islamic State invaded ancient
Christian regions around the Nineveh
plane, June 2015, it again declared,
"We offer them, the Assyrian Christians,
three choices. Islam, the dimmer
contract involving payment of Jiza. If
they refuse this, they will have nothing
but the sword."
The Islamic State is not alone in
calling for Jiza from Christian
infidels. In 2002, Saudi shake Muhammad
bin Abdul Rahman discussing the Muslim
prophet's prediction that Islam will
eventually conquer Rome said, "We will
control the land of the Vatican. We will
control Rome and introduce Islam in it."
Yes, the Christians will yet pay us the
Jiza in humiliation or they will convert
to Islam. A prominent imam, Shik Isam
Amira, gave a sermon in the Al Axa
mosque in Jerusalem in which he lamented
that too many Muslims think that jihad
is only for defense against aggressors
when in fact Muslims are also obligated
to wage offensive jihad against
non-Muslims. When you face your pagan
enemy, call them either to Islam Jiza or
seek Allah's help and fight them. Even
if they do not fight or initiate
hostilities, fight them. fight them when
when they fight you. No, when they
refuse to convert to Islam or refuse to
pay Jiza, whether they like it or not,
we will subjugate them to Allah's
authority.
The doctrine and history of Jiza.
So what exactly is
Jiza? The word Jiza appears in Quran
surah at Toba verse 29 in an injunction
that should be familiar by now. Fight
those among the people of the book,
which are Christians and Jews, who do
not believe in Allah, nor the last day,
nor forbid what Allah and his messenger
have forbidden, nor embrace the religion
of truth until they pay the Jiza with
willing submission and feel themselves
subdued. In Hadith Sahim Muslim 1731A,
the messenger of Allah Muhammad
regularly calls on Muslims to demand
jiza of non-Muslims. If they refuse to
accept Islam, demand from them the Jiza.
If they agree to pay, accept it from
them and hold off your
hands. If they refuse to pay Jiza, seek
Allah's help and fight
them. The second righteous caiff, Omar
al- Katab, reportedly said, "Any
conquered infidel who refuses to convert
to Islam must pay the Jiza out of
humiliation and loneliness. If they
refuse this, it is the sword without
leniency."
This theme of non-Muslim degradation
appears regularly in the commentaries of
Islam's authorities. According to the
medieval Islamic civilization
encyclopedia, Muslim jurists came to
view certain repressive and humiliating
aspects of dimma as
duris subjugated non-Muslim Christians
and Jews were required to pay the jiza
publicly in broad daylight with hands
turned palm upward and to receive a
smart smack on the forehead or the nape
of the neck from the collection officer.
Some of Islam's jurists mandated a
number of other humiliating rituals at
the time of Jiza payment, including that
the presiding Muslim official slap,
choke, and in some cases pull the beard
of the paying demi, who might even be
required to approach the official on all
fours in bestial fashion.
Put simply, conquered non-Muslims like
us must pay for our lives, which would
otherwise be forfeited to the Muslim
conquerors. Instead of taking our lives,
they took our money. Our lives and
possessions are protected only by the
payment of Jiza.
Past and increasingly present, Muslims
profited immensely by exacting Jiza from
conquered peoples. For instance, Amarban
Alas, the companion of Prophet Muhammad
who conquered Christian Egypt in the
early 640s, tortured and killed any
Christian cop who tried to conceal his
wealth. When a cop inquired of him, "How
much Jiza are we to pay?" The Islamic
hero replied, "If you give me all that
you own from the ground to the ceiling,
I will not tell you how much you owe.
Instead, you Christian cops are our
treasure chest so that if we are in
need, you will be in need. And if things
are easy for us, they will be easy for
you."
Yet even that was not enough. Khalif
Uman later chided Amar bin Alas because
another governor of Egypt had managed to
increase our treasury twice as much as
you had. You had to milk the camels, the
Christians of Egypt to produce more
milk.
Years later, yet another caiff, Sulaman
Abdul Malik, wrote to the governor of
Egypt advising him, "You better milk the
camel more until it gives no more milk
and until it milks blood."
Little wonder Egypt went from being
almost entirely Christian in the 7th
century to today having a mere 10% and
steadily dwindling thanks to ongoing
persecution Christian
minority. Related to the idea of
institutionalized Jiza is the notion
that non-Muslims are fair game to
plunder whenever possible. According to
the Jiza entry in the original edition
of the encyclopedia of Islam first
published in 1913 with or without
doctrinal justification arbitrary
demands for money appeared at times.
Even that medieval traveler Marco Polo
whose chronicles appear impartial made
an interesting observation concerning
the Muslims in Tories modernday Iraq in
the 13th century. According to their
doctrine, Islam, whatever is stolen or
plundered from others of a different
faith is properly taken and the theft is
no crime. Whilst those who suffer death
or injury by the hands of Christians
during the course of a plunder-driven
raid are considered as
martyrs. These principles are common to
all Sarris Muslims. All this is echoed
in recent times by the words of Shik Abu
Ishakal Hawaii spoken a few years ago
concerning what the Muslim world should
do to overcome its economic problems.
[Laughter]
Okay.
Foreign speech. Foreign speech. Foreign
speech.
foreign. So it was for well over a
millennium Muslim rulers and mobs
extorted money from infidels under their
sway as a legitimate way to
profit. Much of this financial fleecing
came to an end thanks to direct European
intervention. Beginning in the mid-9th
century, one Muslim region after another
abolished the Jiza and gave non-Muslims
unprecedented rights, originally to
appease Western powers, later in
emulation of Western
governance. The Ottoman Empire's hot
e-humayun decree of 1856 abolished the
Jiza in many Ottoman ruled territories.
Elsewhere in the Muslim world, the Jiza
was gradually abolished wherever Western
western powers were
present. Today, however, as Muslims
reclaim their Islamic heritage, often to
the approval and encouragement of a West
now under the spell of multiculturalism,
Jiza, whether institutionalized as under
the Islamic State or as a rationale to
plunder infidels, is back. Even in the
West, in 2013, a UK Muslim preacher who
was receiving more than £25,000 annually
in welfare benefits referred to British
taxpayers as slaves and explained, "We
take the Jiza, which is our hawk."
Anyway, the normal situation, by the
way, is to take money from the kafir,
isn't it? So, this is the normal
situation. They give us the money. You
work, give us the money, Allah abar, we
take the money.
academic lies about
Jiza. Yet if Muslims from Islamic State
jihadis to Egyptian university
professors know the truth about Jiza,
the West is today oblivious thanks to
its leading authorities on Islam.
Western academics and other experts and
talking heads. Consider the following
excerpt from John Espazito, director of
the Prince Alwaled Center for Muslim
Christian Understanding at Georgetown
University and a widely acknowledged
go-to source for anything Islamic. In
many ways, local populations, the
Christians, Jews, and others found
Muslim rule more flexible and tolerant
than that of Bzantium and Persia.
Religious communities were free to
practice their faith to worship and be
governed by their religious leaders and
laws in such areas as marriage, divorce,
and inheritance. In exchange, they were
required to pay tribute, a pole tax or
jiza that entitled them to Muslim
protection from outside aggression and
exempted them from military service.
Thus, they were called the protected
ones or demi. In effect, this often
meant lower taxes, greater local
autonomy. Despite the almost gushing
tone related to Muslim rule, the idea
that Jizia was extracted in order to buy
Muslim protection from outside
aggression is an outright lie. Equally
false is Esposito's assertion that Jiza
was paid to exempt them non-Muslims from
military service, as if conquering
Muslims would even want or allow their
conquered infidel subjects to fight
alongside them in the name of jihad
without first converting to
Islam. In reality, and as demonstrated
above via the words of a variety of
authoritative Muslims, past and present,
Jiza was and is indeed protection money,
though protection not from outsiders, as
Espazito and others claim, but from
surrounding Muslims themselves. Whether
it is the first caliphate from over a
millennium ago or whether it is the
newest caliphate, the Islamic State,
Muslim overlords continue to deem the
lives of their infidel subjects forfeit
unless they purchase it, ransom it with
money.
Put differently, the subjugated infidel
is a beast to be milked until it gives
no more milk till it milks blood. to
quote the memorable words of an early
calip
there is nothing humane reasonable or
admirable about demands for Jiza from
conquered non-Muslim minorities as the
academics
claim Jiza is simply extortion money its
purpose has always been to provide
non-Muslims with protection from Muslims
pay up or else convert to Islam or else
die
shut up you just shut up and pay up okay
in Short jiza is yet another ugly fact
of Islam. Add to offensive jihad,
imperialism, misogyny, slavery, etc. One
that distort as they may, the academics
cannot whitewash away even as the world
stands idly by watching its resumption
in the 21st century.